it's the biggest strike in a decade up
to half a million workers walked out
today and there's no compromise in sight
but at what cost to everyone else let's
break it down with millions of civil
servants teachers and Railway workers
staying at home economists believe these
lost working days have directly cost the
economy 68 million pounds for anyone who
has had to cancel a train journey in
recent months will know that there is a
much wider ripple effect when you
include all those that were unable to
get to work because of the strikes the
cost balloons to 94 million pounds
making it the costliest day of strike
action over the past eight months and
then there are others who couldn't go to
work because schools were closed today's
attendance records from the Department
of Education show that more than half of
schools were either closed or partially
closed that's over 8 000 schools
disrupted
and with parents for going the school
run today or skipping the commute to
stay at home you may have noticed that
the roads were quieter than usual
real-time traffic data shows that there
was far less congestion on the roads
than usual during the morning Rush Hour
this was the picture in Bristol at 9 00
a.m this morning where traffic was down
by 43 percent compared to the previous
week and it was the same in Liverpool
and on London on the tube Network the
number of entries and the exits well
they were down 23 to 1.39 million while
the number of bus Journeys fell by 18 to
1.12 million a clear sign then that
industrial action and the failure to
reach a settlement is undermining
economic activity in Britain